[Music]
could jetpacks like this ever be used to
help us get around for decades jetpacks
only existed in films like thunderball
or the rocketeer but in the past few
years a handful of inventors around the
world have tried to turn the idea into a
reality one of those companies is
startup gravity industries that have
developed this iron man-like jet pack
but since it became a reality the jet
pack has kind of been a solution in
search of a problem and has only really
been used for entertainment at stunt
shows now however military and medical
professionals have begun exploring
whether a jetpack could change how
efficiently they get from a to b
it got me wondering just how far jetpack
technology could take us so that's why
i'm here at the goodwood motor circuit
in the back of this land rover being
taken to gravity's rig where they're
gonna strap me in and i'm gonna get to
experience this thing for myself
let's go
okay first a little history about
gravity industries jetpack the company
was founded in 2017 by inventor richard
browning who self-funded the design and
build of a prototype jetpack simply to
see if it was possible since then
richard says he's received over 750 000
in investment and has been flying around
in his jet fuel-powered suit
entertaining crowds breaking some speed
records and occasionally falling into
the water to help prepare me for my
flight and tell me a little bit more
about where jetpack technology is headed
richard dropped in for a little chat
he likes to make an entrance richard
welcome
we've actually started to uncover real
practical applications of this paramedic
response and special forces mobility are
just two of the examples gravity
recently conducted tests in the north of
england to see how efficiently a first
responder could reach the summit of a
mountain if using a jet pack the jet
pack would be used to get immediate
medical attention to a casualty but
couldn't be used to get them down from
the mountain it takes 70 minutes for the
mountain rescue people so over an hour
for the mountain rescue people to walk
to the top we managed to summit that
mountain in three and a half minutes and
the top was completely shrouded in fog
so no helicopter could have got to you
either gravity has also been working
with the uk's naval forces to test
whether the jet pack could be used as a
better way to transfer troops from one
ship to another richard said it takes
around three minutes with helicopters
and ropes but he said the jet pack took
16 seconds and it's not just emergency
services in the uk that are exploring
this technology american firm jetpack
aviation told me that they had sold
jetpacks to a south east asian
government for military use now until
recently the only people who could
really fly gravity's jetsuit were either
richard or his employees that means that
neither the navy nor the paramedics have
actively used this technology yet but
we've actually now trained up real
paramedics and hopefully in the summer
we're going to have them actually on
standby ready to
respond hopefully to the first real-life
casualty so how easy is it to fly a jet
pack there's only one way to find out
let's get you in yeah let's do it
getting rigged into this thing was not a
comfortable process give yourself a lot
of us
that looks great the straps had to be
super tight and the pack was weighed
down with a lot of fuel which was still
only enough to give me around three
minutes of flight i was told i'd be able
to control the thrust by pressing this
button here but a safety supervisor
would control how much power was going
to the engines technically even with the
weight of the fuel the suit is so light
and wingless that it's exempt from many
aviation authority regulations so no
need to register my flight plan so um
let's go flying now richard tells me the
suit can comfortably cruise at up to 60
miles an hour i'm walking up here i did
kind of have some hopes of looking at
least a little bit like iron man
one
but that wasn't the case
at all and yes i am fully aware how
ridiculous i look i was initially
started off on low power but after a few
moments i started to get a feel for how
the jets were pushing my body into the
air so i had one quick go at hovering
and just as i was starting to get a feel
for it
we'd have to stop there okay low on fuel
three minutes of bouncing around had
burned through my pack's fuel supply my
flight experience if you can call it
that was finished as were my ironman
ambitions richard told me i did really
well i don't believe him i mean it's the
most expensive baby bouncer i've ever
been in
so where is jetpack technology headed
for now gravity says its main revenue
stream will continue to be through
entertainment they'll do jetpack shows
offer people paid flying experiences and
plan on launching a jetpack racing
series in 2023
but could this technology find even more
uses well richard says for now it's
unlikely that a jet pack will ever
become your daily driver and having
flown one i can see why are you going to
go to the shops pick the kids ups in
school or go to commute in a thousand
horsepower jetsuit it's as practical as
taking a formula one car the company has
tried making the jetpack electric which
could mean a quieter less flammable suit
but heavy batteries meant it could only
fly for 10 seconds however richard told
me new people were continuing to
approach him with new potential uses for
this tech so we we deliberately are on
this upward spiral with an enormous
community of people in many different
sectors so until jetpack technology
becomes cheaper lighter and more fuel
efficient it's likely it's going to
struggle to get off the ground just like
me
[Music]